there was some lunatic mother who went
on abc news the other day and talked
about how from her daughter's
very first words
she began to identify
as a girl she was a it was a boy but
then identified as a girl
when chassis our daughter when she
really started to
communicate to us and that was at the
earliest moment that she actually had
words and language
to communicate to us who she truly was
we were a little surprised because we
didn't expect it and then as we just
literally
raised her
supported her just like all parents do
raising you know we're teaching her the
right values we're teaching her to give
back
you know one of her favorite things in
the world to do is to volunteer and be
in service to others you know that
surprise
evolves into something just really
cool and important and and that is the
realization that she's our daughter
that's the realization she had af when
she started saying google we just knew
we just anyone who's ever had a child
knows that this is preposterous first of
all it's it's preposterous because your
kids first words are like you know doggy
right your kids first words don't even
sound like words they're just kind of
sounds and so this woman is
projecting something i don't know what
she's projecting and then it's so sad
because she shows photos of her son who
she's dressed up as a little girl and
it's obviously he's he's a boy he's a
boy it's obviously a boy and i i think
the the pictures here are the key to it
because you hear these lunatic women
like this this person here men and women
but this woman in particular and she
says my my
eight-month-old baby obviously was
transgender and you say this woman's
offer rocker and she's saying the same
kinds of things that elected democrats
are saying she's saying the same kinds
of things that the white house is
pushing right now and then you see it
you see it's so clear you see it in what
your kids being taught which became very
clear during covet when kids were being
taught online you see it when you look
at the picture and you say no the boy
actually isn't a girl and the girl
actually isn't a boy and we're careening
toward the midterms right now and this
is not going to go very well for
democrats right now go to expressvpn.com
knowles we know that big tech doesn't
like us we know that they target us for
our views so why are you letting them
peek in and look at everything you're
looking at on the internet every even
when you use that special super secret
incognito window
you're not hiding your data from these
big tech companies
i'm talking about when you're looking at
websites that you shouldn't be looking
at recording you know what i'm talking
about those websites that could get you
in trouble
you know i'm talking about
dailywire.com you know what i mean you
don't want big tech knowing about that
that's probably the worst thing you
could be looking at
especially in a day when when people are
really being persecuted for their
political views expressvpn anonymizes
your online activity camouflages your ip
address replaces it with a different
secure ip of your choice i don't go on
without it i've got it on all my devices
i love it it's the number one rated vpn
provider go to expressvpn.com
knowles get three months for free on a
one year package exp
ressvpn.com slash knowles expressvpn.com
knowles head on over there to check out
the vpn that i trust i'm glad you like
that clip now
subscribe ring that bell get the
notifications better yet subscribe to
the michael knowles show on apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
leave a five-star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]